okay today I'm going to talk to you
about mole calculations we're going to
have a look at how to find a number of
moles in a particular substance and
we're going to have a look at more
calculations when we're talking about
solutions so we might get a question
which is like this how many moles are
there in sixty six grams of carbon
dioxide of co2 now whenever we have a
question like this we can use this
equation triangle right here now first
of all let's figure out what these three
things mean and just means number of
moles now we need a little recap quickly
about what moles means now all that the
mole is is a number of particles an
amount of particles a mole is 6.02 times
10 to the 23 so it's a really really big
number so that's just saying how many
particles there are in total the M
stands for mass now whenever we're
dealing with moles the units for mass is
always grams opposed to kilograms and
finally M R this stands for relative
formula mass now this could also stand
for relative atomic mass but because
this one is a molecule rather than an
element this particular question is to
do with relative formula mass so let's
see how this works now if I'm looking to
find the number of moles to use this
equation triangle I'm going to cover up
that and I'm left with M over m R so M
divided by M R now before I could do
this I've got to find my relative
formula mass of carbon dioxide so let's
just have a quick thing now in co2 in
co2 I have one carbon atom and two
oxygen atoms so I need to find the total
relative atomic mass and both the
relative atomic mass of both of these
elements and add them together so here's
where my periodic table comes in handy I
could see that carbon has a mass of 12
an oxygen has a mass
sixteen so what I need to do is twelve
plus because I've got two oxygen atoms I
need to do 16 times 2 now 16 times 2 is
32 plus 12 is 44 so I've now found my
relative formula mass of co2 so what I
need to do now is if I'm a number of
moles so how many particles there are I
need to do my mass divided by my
relative formula mass so my mass in the
question is right here and my so I need
to do to find my number of moles it's a
number of moles is 66 because it's over
it's divided by 44 so my number of moles
in this case is 66 divided by 44 so I'm
just going to do that in the calculator
66 divided by 44 which equals one point
five so we're number of moles is one
point five moles what that means just so
we can make sense of what that actually
means is in 66 grams of co2 there are
1.5 times this many particles that's
just what that means
now there's one type of calculation we
might also be asked about calculations
when we're dealing with a solution so
for example 25 grams of copper sulfate
is dissolved in 500 centimeters cube of
water what is the concentration now
whenever we have a solution so something
dissolved in water we use this equation
triangle instead again we have M which
stands for mass and again because we're
dealing with mole calculations the units
are in grams the volume now whenever
we're dealing with these we have volume
but whenever we're doing mole
calculations the volume is in decimetres
cubed rather than centimeters cubed so
we're gonna have to do a conversion
in a minute that there's our volume and
finally we have C which stands for
concentration now our units for
concentration because we have grams
divided by over decimeters q the units
of grams per decimeter cubed so let's
have a quick thing we're looking to find
the concentration and hit right here
there is our mass so before we can do
this calculation we need to convert this
into decimetres cubed so it's inverse
centimeters cubed adesso meters cubed we
divide by a thousand so 500 divided by a
thousand equals 0.5 decimeters cubed
half a decimeter cubed okay I'm now
ready to find my concentration so to
find the concentration it's the same as
using any equation triangle I cover up
the thing I'm looking for and I
calculate with the two things I've got
left so in this case it's going to be a
mass divided by my volume so my
concentration is gonna be my mass which
is 25 divided by my volume which is 0.5
so I'm going to do that on my calculator
just to double-check remember even if
you think you're do it in your head
always do a calculator don't use the
calculator to double-check 25 divided by
0.5 is 50 so my concentration is 50 and
remember the units for concentration is
grams per decimeter cubed so that's how
to complete mole calculations when you
try to find the moles number of moles of
a substance we use this equation
triangle here and whenever we wanna find
the moles when we're talking about a
solution you use this equation triangle
here and remember to always
convert your volume to decimeters cubed
thank you